ليرصد اكثر عمليات الانقاذ في هذا المبنى
وانا اتابع الحديث نعم طاهر فعلا يعني انا
هذا المبنى هو احد اكبر المباني يعني 14
طابقا انهار بالكامل في اضنه هذا المبنى
يعتبر من اكبر المباني المهدمه تقريبا
عمليات الانقاذ شارفت على النهايه في
حوالي الساعه الثانيه بعد منتصف الليل قبل
حوالي ساعتين انتشرت فرق الانقاذ جثتين من
هذا المبنى طبعا
الاعمال ما زالت تتواصل يعني صحيح ان اننا
على اعتاب عشر دقائق وندخل اليوم الخامس
عشر دقائق بالضبط ادخل اليوم الخامس لوقوع
هذه الكارثه لكن ما زال هناك امل لدى فرق
الانقاذ خصوصا انه معثروا صباح الخميس اي
قبل حوالي اقل حتى من 24 ساعه على شخص كان
على قيد الحياه في هذا المبنى لكن طاهر
يعني حتى
نعيد معلومه ذكرناها في النشاط الماضيه
فرق مختصه من الجيش التركي وصلت الى هنا
الى هذا الموقع مساء امس وبدات عمليات
الاشراف على عمليه على اكتمال عمليات
ازاله الانقاض والبحث على ناجين هي فرقه
متخصصه بالتعاطمه هذا النوع من الكوارث
طبعا تم نقل قسم من المتطوعين الذين كانوا
هنا لا ادري اذا كانت الكاميرا تستطيع رصد
عناصر من الجيش التركي هنا في هذه في
زاويه
في القسم الايمن من هذا الموقع ساطلب من
زميلي ان يحرك الكاميرا الى هناك ويخبرني
بان الصوره باتت واضحه عناصر من الجيش
الجيش التركي مع نعم عناصر من الجيش
التركي مع ايضا عناصر من هيئه الطوارئ
والكوارث التركيه المعروفه اختصارا هنا
باسم افاد
يواصلون العمل
حتى اتمام اخر
اتابع معكم هناك انتشال جثه جديده الان في
هذه الاثناء فرق الفرق الطبيه وعناصر
الجيش ينتشلون جثه اضافيه من هذا الموقع
نتمنى ان تتكلم جهودهم قريبا بالعثور على
ناجي اخر
ما زال على قيد الحياه الان انتشار جثه من
هذا الموقع مباشره شاهدناها عبر شاشه
العربيه
ننتظر ايضا اخبار
نامل ان تكون ايجابيه سواء من هذا الموقع
او المواقع الاخرى طاهر يعني
اليوم الخامس سيدخل وجهود الانقاذ ما زالت
مستمره احد رجال او احد
اطقم الانقاذ اخبرنا في وقت سابق ان معظم
الجثث التي تم انتشارها او حتى الاشخاص
الذين عثروا عليهم وهم على قيد الحياه
كانوا في منطقه السلالم او منطقه درج
الرئيسي في البنايه في هذا البناء وهم
كانوا يحاولون الفرار عندما انهارت او
انهار البناء بالاكمل على من فيه اخبرنا
انه منذ اليوم الاول كانوا يتوقعون وجود
حوالي 80 شخص تحت الانقاض هي معلومات يعني
يتوقعون بشكل تقريبي او تخميني ليست
معلومات اكيده لا يوجد لديهم ولا حتى لدى
السلطات معلومات اكيده عن اعداد المفقودين
او اعداد المدفونين تحت الانقاض لا في هذا
الموقع ولا في بقيه المواقع في الولايات
في الولايات الاخرى طبعا الحصيله ارتفعت
بشكل كبير ودراماتيكي خلال الساعات
الماضيه واليوم الرابع على وجه التحديد
الحصيله تجاوزت 17 وهي حصيله زلزال ازمه
في عام 1999 اي اننا
نواجه او تركيا تواجه كارثه اكبر من كارثه
الزلزال المميت الذي شهدته ازمه واسطنبول
عام 1999